Michel Basquiat Memoriam explain my dear
countrymen at the moment that I speak to
you terrorist attacks of an
unprecedented level a happening in the
Paris Area there are dozens dead
there are many injured it's a horror we
have at my command mobilised all
possible forces so that we can
neutralize the terrorist threat and
secure all the areas that could be
affected I've also asked for military
reinforcements in the Paris Area to be
sure that another attack cannot take
place
I have also called a cabinet meeting
which will take place shortly two
decisions will be made a state of
emergency will be declared which means
that certain areas will be closed moving
through these areas will not be allowed
the state of emergency will be declared
throughout the country the second
decision I've made
it's the closure of the borders we must
be sure that nobody can enter to commit
whatever acts they may wish to and at
the same time that those who have
committed these crimes can be
apprehended if they are trying to leave
the country